thank
you good evening everybody and welcome
to this meeting of molden District
Council held on Thursday the 14th of
December
2023 my name is councelor Kevin lagen
and I'm the chairman of the council
members and all present we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting
you're giving your consent to being
recorded during each item please put
your hand up to indicate if you wish to
speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate time could I ask members to
avoid approaching this table as it could
create interference with the cameras in
the live stream for those that are
watching please note that the YouTube
live stream sound recording is dependent
on the correct use of microphones
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn your
microphone uh on and turn it off when
you're finished please reference a page
or a paragraph number when referring to
the agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible uh please Don't Unplug any pie
SE or or pack up any items until the
meeting's been DEC closed please okay
Tara apologies for absence
please thank you chairman apologies we
received from counc B counc Bell counc B
coun Miller counc Morgan councel sha and
councelor Sid Norman thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed Tara move on
to agenda item three which is the
minutes so it's the minutes of the 29th
of November 2023 found on pages 5 to 16
your in gender pack to confirm the
minutes to the extraordinary council
meeting held on the 29th of November a
copy en closed any any comments on the
minutes or they Council
fluka thank you chairman um be before I
start chairman can I can I start by
paying tribute to all those in the
emergency services and healthc Care
sectors I think you'll all join me and
thanking them for all the work they do
over the festive break to keep us all
safe wish them and their family uh Happy
Christmas likewise all the members and
chairman sometimes I think it's
thank you for indulging me but I think
sometimes members do get very close to
their communities and and I'd also like
what part of them the minutes CC fluk
please well sadly I've now missed the
opportunity to pay tribute to no we're
not paying tribute we can do that later
on there may be
somethinge minute thank you very much
thank you chairman turning to minute
three what I actually said was the
number of persons shown in the officers
report was inaccurate and that in
reality more persons that actually
attended the meetings and this could be
confirmed by watching the video stream
chairman going to minute 11 on page 10
paragraph 4 with regards to the £45,000
which he's mentioned several times the
assistant director actually said to
start with that this was the cost so far
and then seemed to change that to an
ongoing cost now none of that chairman
is in the minutes and I think it's very
very important because it isn't clear
uh and the importance of that is
Chairman because it was suggested at
that meeting that we were likely to
revisit this in six months time um and
CH chairman moving on to minute
15 members expressed concerns with
regards to the scheme and the lack of a
mayor and the likely impact that that
will have on funding and I really do
think chairman that those comments
should be recorded
um because I think it's right and proper
that our residents understand our
concerns about where we are going with
this Devolution and likewise ter there
were some very disingenuous comments
about Mark fuis and whilst members might
not like to see those in the minutes I
think it's important that they should be
included and I I think that perhaps
somebody should apologize to the the MP
for ra and Wickford um chairman minute
21 one now what page well 15 um chairman
minute 21 now I appreciate that this is
a matter that was dealt with under
section 100a of the Local Government Act
and and I will caution myself chairman
um but chairman that minute in my mind
is very
unbalanced uh and I appreciate the
minutes aren't for batim but I think if
you say one thing and it's been counted
by something else both should be
included so chairman it was stated
during during the debate that members
had on many occasions questioned the the
resale value of the property and
chairman in the matter of openness and
transparencies that should be recorded
in the minutes likewise
chairman the fact that we expended more
than a quarter of a million pounds of
taxpayers funds on what is now an
aborted project the taxpayers need to
know that there's absolutely no way or
Reason that you can withhold that
information under section 100a of the of
of of the Local Government Act and also
chairman you might remember I questioned
the content of paragraph
5.4.1 again that's not included in in
the minutes and and this was to do with
smarter
finances and the comment under 5.4.1 was
completely uh ads odds with the tone of
that report and I seemed somebody said
at the time it was it it was something
like they're the right words but in the
wrong order which reminds me of that
thing um with Eric morham and uh that
Andre prev the right notes but in the
wrong order but chairman these things
are important and they should be in the
minutes so chairman I I propose subject
to that I'm quite happy to agree the
meeting the me the minutes of the
meeting there's a lot um there as you
say there the the minutes are not um a
the btim record of the meeting and
there's a recording for anybody to to to
look at to to get further information
from that so I'm a bit at a loss really
to to say what parts you would want
amending that are actually I'll happily
go through them again well no I don't
think I think chairman can I also remind
you of course the agenda item 21 was not
recorded because although it's always
been my argument that some the most
important things that we should recall
are uh items are dealt with in PNC yeah
I'll just refer to the legal officer
please so just to respond than thank you
yeah chairman obviously style of minutes
will vary from local authority to local
Authority um but the purpose of minutes
is to primarily record the decision
made
and give a preamble to that decision
it's not they're not designed to
include things that particular one
member particularly thinks are important
or because there may be things that
other members think if they actually
wanted to that they would like a
particular comment in minutes are there
really just to give the the bare
framework of why a decision was made and
particularly when we go into p and C
details about finances were the very
reason that uh the membership actually
decided to go and treat it as exempt
information so the amount of money the
organization spent would would be
within um the PNC element now it's true
if there is a resolution by Council that
they want that in the minutes then that
is so but the the minting the the
committee clar quite rightly have not
included that because it's PNC
information
yep yeah St yeah thank you chairman
don't want to delay it much longer but I
mean I think is it's only fair I agree
with some of what council fluka said it
has to be balanced so if you are going
to put one thing forward because I've
often said that sometimes the minutes at
this Council can be biased and I think
if you're going to actually put them put
put both sides thing or don't put
anything just put the resolution I think
from the perspective when I reviewed the
minutes and trust me I review them and I
review them and then I go through and
review them again um I was I was happy
with with was actually minuted by the
committee clerk so unless there's a
specific proposal or recommendation to
change any of those minutes um is there
or is there not the members are
generally happy with the minutes as they
stand so agree theair I I I would ask
chairman that my vote is recorded and I
don't support that because there for a
variety of reasons and I'm I'm more than
happy to meet the monitoring office to
discuss those reasons um as you can do
councelor fluka with pleasure I would
like to see bit more balance in the
reporting of minutes thank you councelor
fluk Atara did you catch that the
minutes were agreed by Ascent with the
exception of councilor Fluker
please coun I've got that thank you very
much thank you could I just add um an
apology for absence from councelor
wiffin please yeah thank you Sor an
wiffin thank you thank you thank you
members we'll move on to number four
Declaration of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosure
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-registered interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that
they're also required to disclose such
an interest as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting members do we have any
declarations please councelor
darham thank you chairman um yeah I have
an other registerable interest in
relation to item 13 on tonight tonight's
agenda because I'm a Cabinet member at
ess6 County Council and I'm aware of
information regarding that topic that is
not in the public domain thank you thank
you councelor Dar any other
members no well thank you very much
indeed members uh we move on to agenda
item five which is public questions
we've received one question uh which has
be responded to in writing by the
leader number six agenda item six which
is chairperson's announcements uh I just
want to announce that this year we
myself and the vice chair held a staff
lunch and with the help and support of
the directors uh which is very well
received and it was a lovely occasion
and we've got some lovely feedback so um
just want to share that with all members
um agenda item seven members is the
minute book to consider the
recommendations coming forward from the
Committees detailed below please not
that the minutes of these meetings are
not en closes have not been approved at
committee level and this is a strategy
and resources Committee of the 23rd of
November 2023 pages
17-32 and there is a recommendation
under agenda item 10 fees and charges
schedule
2024 but before I move to that um Miss
Lucas I believe you wish to comment on
the
report yeah thank you chair um so just
to remind members at the last council
meeting um we pointed out that the fees
and charge policy which was separately
agreed didn't reflect the previous counc
decision to um uh apply a 50% discount
to warid fees and charges
so just to point out to members that
that has now been reflected in the um
updated schedule which is presented for
members approvals tonight um in addition
to that I just wanted to note a couple
of other um minor amendments um so in
the previous version that went to um
strategy and resources committee there
was um a fee line um for Open Spaces
Memorial bench fees um but that has now
been deleted as again there was a
previous decision by Council not to um
not to include that so that that's that
line has been deleted and the third
point I just wanted to make was in
relation to the the green waste charges
the halfe charge which was within the
schedule is shown as40 within the report
but that should be £35 um and that
reflects the um proed fee of the foure
£70 which um again has been put forward
by strategy and resources committee so
um I'd propose that the um fees and
charges schedule um recommended by
straty and resources is is agree
um yeah subject to that that one
Amendment on the um green waste halfe
charge thank you thank you very much
indeed Miss Lucas before I move on to
the recommendation Council fluke you've
approached me that you have some
comments on
these chairman yes I I I do but I mean
chairman i' I've got several comments to
make and and can I just uh remind
members that the decision by the
strategy and resources committee was not
unanimous to support these fees and
charges and I think that is worth
bearing in mind chairman I've I've got a
few um
questions um so I mean I rather I don't
know if anybody else has got any
questions but rather than if other
members have perhaps they could indicate
to you chairman and we could go through
it Page by Page or or I'll take mine as
they go but it would mean officers
dipping in and out yeah well we I think
we could has anybody else got any um
questions or queries points to make on
these so I think um appears I've got the
floor thank you chairman yes um right
chairman so we'll go through Page 17 U
no I'm fine chairman I'll start I'll
start on page 19 um chairman we've we've
um we no longer provide pest control
ourselves but chairman if we had a
signposting system on our website
chairman uh local companies rather than
just us referring to them um they would
probably pay us to go on the referral
system uh the same as the nights ago
compare do so PS officers should pick up
on that chairman but the the one that
cons concerns me and residents
enormously chairman is is on page um 19
as well which is under Recycling and
this is the green bins chairman um
members might not be aware particularly
those that don't uh serve on the one of
the one of the U I think the waste
contract working group um the this
service generates a surplus of 37 £7,000
a year um and chman it's the the
intent um of I presume I I I don't know
whose policies these are I've lost track
of everything now on policy um so I'll
say the officers so the officers are
going are planning to increase the green
bin fee which in my mind chairman is a
is an an additional Taxation and burden
on those that subscribe to recycling the
reason why we have green beans is so
that we can recycle our gardenways I
think Council fluka that whilst I I
appreciate what you're saying key thing
is just just to be clear on this because
I know there's several and I will pull
the Constitution and I will use the time
allowed to speak if I need to but I want
you to also be heard so what I'm saying
is that just to say officers put the
recommendation to committees committees
put the recommendation to council so
ultimately we make that decision
chairman the committee is not sovereign
to this this Council will make the
ultimate decision based on what I'm
proposing chairman I'm proposing
chairman in in relation to recycling and
green beans that there is no increase
chairman I mean anybody that's got a
green bin um listening to this is seeing
that we make this enormous Surplus and
now we're just we're now just going to
whack up the price of the green bins for
£10 so chairman my proposal is that the
green bin waste fee does not change um
this is a blatant
moneymaking um operation by this Council
it's it's typical of what I've seen in
the last year like going for the low
fruit so you've you put a prop a
recommendation that there no increase is
that
seconded okay that proposal not seconded
thank you councelor fluk you need moving
on um chairman again chairman I don't
know how much work's done on this but
I'm still on page 19 and and can I thank
everybody for taxing all the people that
have got green bins let's stick to the
agenda rather than political Capital
so that's what it is so we need to move
through this agenda there's some really
important points on here there's no
political Capital be gain by saving the
environment CH so chairman page 19 elri
to run the meeting page page 19 Refuge
collections chairman if you look at the
volume of what we're proposing to
collect against the PES um chairman
that's about about a third of the price
of a skip I mean I really do think
someone needs to look at these prices J
these charges fees and then moving on
chairman you'll be pleased to know now
that um I'm now on to page uh 23 you um
chairman I I wonder if officers can can
confirm why the the season ticket to
park a vehicle on high key is so low and
PS whil officers are considering that
they might like to answer why nobody
down there this evening had a permit on
their
car uh and then chairman moving
on to
um page 23 Town Center car Parks
chairman again I don't understand this
it says T Town Center car Parks resident
season ticket and it but the season
ticket is only for a Monday and it says
Monday 5 to 10 an all day Sundays 86 per
anom I mean I I really don't I mean
we're being asked to to agree the fees
the schedule of fees and charges and I I
I I've got no idea what that means I
think it means that you can park on a
Monday evening only between 5 10:00 and
all day on a Sunday throughout the year
for £88 or whatever it is 8870 so
chairman I think that needs an
explanation should we just um before we
go on because they're twoo interl should
we um I F this to officers to see Please
Mr
holes chairman I think Mrs greed will be
able to help with the carping items you
might need to repeat because the
microphone is not very clear from
Council fluka so um if you perap
summarize for for Mrs Green she should
to answer council fluka could you
summarize for us please well chairman
the last one I mentioned was the
resident season ticket Town Center car
parks and the fact that it's only on
Mondays between 5 and 10 uh an all day
on Sunday and um my other was to do with
high key uh where the season ticket
seems to be inexplicably
low thank you councelor fla Miss green
welcome
um apologies chairman unfortunately the
the line um is cutting out so I'm
struggling to hear councel fluk question
I wonder perhaps if um someone could
relay that by the team's message my
apologies
okay what we'll do is we'll we'll move
past that for a moment while while we
seem to get that item address I'll now
go to page 24 because I know you're
quite keen and chairman again with I'm
going to speak to beach Huts now um
chairman these daily charges of 58 and
30 proposals I noticed first of all that
we're not increasing the charges of the
beat charts but chairman I again I do
wonder where these charges originate
from because surely after the beach hut
has been let we have to pay somebody to
go in and clean it uh and I can't really
see how a fee of £37 for a half day less
a cleaning fee less the administration
cost of collecting that
£37 makes any sense business-wise at all
so chairman maybe one of the officers
would like to come back on that and then
chairman I'll move quickly on to uh
page
25 uh page 25 chairman and and again
something else I don't understand and
it's towards the top and it says um
cricket cricket per game and then it
says Sports pitch use parking season
ticket per Club
£45 I mean does that mean that they can
like the club get a season ticket for
the 11 men uh and the score in the
cricket plus the people I I mean none of
this really makes any sense chairman I
think I think that needs and then
chairman you moving on again if we come
down again we we're talking about
changing rooms booking changing rooms
and it says here £4 chairman to book a a
changing room well again surely it has
to be cleaned at the end of the booking
so I I suspect we're working in cost
negative here and this is the council
that
excluding uh investment income he's
looking at a deficit of 2 and A2 million
quid in a couple of years
time and then chairman do we want to
just to refer Mr Holmes is is it able to
answer those questions at this point
certainly give
away would you rather write till all the
questions have been
levied as we go chairman there's quite a
lot of detailed um questions here this
evening I have to say the F and charges
are very similar to they have been in
the past and obviously um unfortunately
we haven't had any notification this
question so we need to we need to think
through the response to council fuker
yeah what I'm thinking is Council fuker
I mean the officers have been working on
this report since it um probably several
weeks before it went to strategy and
resources but I look forward to uh um
hearing the responses but again it's
very difficult to agree these uh with so
much information is missing to make an
informed decision so chairman I I I I
think that um I know other people now
want to speak on the fees and charges so
I'll give
way
yeah okay what what my thinking is
members and council fuka is with the
exceptions of those those points that
have been raised um by councelor fluka
to to look at approving the fees and
charges schedule as is with the
exception of those individual
items
yeah well I'm putting it to the the the
the chamber it's not your decision on
mine it's the chambers so thank you so
that's okay leader no I I understand um
but it's difficult because we want to
get we want to get these agreed and get
them out so that officers can start to
to action them but I also think some of
the points that councelor Flo has
actually raised a very valid um so we
find ourselves in a little bit of a
sticky position because the
recommendations from the strategy and
resources committee have come through
you know they've they've looked at this
carefully and put the recommendation to
council and you've gone through with a
fine tooth comb so councelor fluka
chairman an easy solution to this might
be is Chairman if we we agree
this we uh we agree the fees and charges
with the exceptions that I spoken to and
perhaps um chairman you in conjunction
with the chairman of strategy and
resources and the appropriate director
uh could look at the responses to my
questions and make an informed
decision raise all these issues okay
yeah that's a fair point so you're on
strategy and resources councelor fluky
yeah you're on that committee why just
why didn't you raise them at that point
chairman I think if you if you uh listen
as I said that it was not it was not a
unanimous decision some people voted
against the fees and charges because of
green waste and other matters and and
chairman I if one listens to the tape
chairman I think the the chairman was
not so generous as you with allowing
people to speak uh there was an awful
lot to get through on that night uh and
and I I did raise some of these points
chairman but you're absolutely right
others I didn't uh but then again that's
why we have chairman the sovereignty of
council where these decisions can be
discussed uh or should I say these
matters can be discussed and decisions
made but this is a hugely important
document and the impact on residence is
is tremendous chair particularly green
waste okay we've got a couple of other
speakers so I'd go to councelor moley
first and then councelor Daren please
thank you chairman um we're
just really on um the
waste um the co the charges that the
council will entail soon will be quite
High um in particular rigid plastic has
tanked from 40 a ton to we're now paying
to get rid of it to 25 a ton
cardboard is there's nothing on it now
so this is why I think you got to be
careful you can't just agree you you you
the prices will have to go up a bit I'm
afraid mhm well you can't export there's
no export anymore for Waste they've
completely stopped
it okay I do get it you get it yeah but
but you have to
charge no but it is going to be
extremely expensive yeah okay thank you
councel councelor AR
please chairman as you rightly say this
was debated actually at some length um
and I recall councilor fluka mentioning
certainly the green waste um at strategy
and resources and this was the
Democratic resolution of the strategy
resources uh committee which we're
bringing to for Council for um agreement
tonight and I I think in actual fact
councelor fluga mentioned that the the
net
profit um being a public authority of
course we don't make profit we make
savings or surpluses but um I think the
feig the figure of £300,000 I'm not
entirely sure that that is correct I'm
sure miss Lucas will correct me if I'm
wrong but I don't believe it was
anywhere near that amount um and and as
councelor Moy has said you know the
costs are going up um in relation to um
the uh the cost of recycling and the hey
days that we've had in the past of
making the surpluses from recyclers um
are are long gone so as I said chairman
this was
debated um more than once in actual fact
and you'll recall you I allowed you to
come and speak um chairman um in
relation to the warid charges sorry are
other people speaking sorry um uh you
came and spoke yourself you were at that
meeting um and we uh we addressed the
situation that that you brought to us so
uh strategy resources um agreed these uh
fees and charges and I would hope that
Council ratifies them thank you thank
you Council d uh Council F please um
yeah thank you chair I mean I I I do see
councilor F's point in as much as there
are some items that perhaps could have
deserved more attention but in the wider
picture these are relatively small items
that will have a very limited impact on
the overall budget um should they be
increased so I think the sensible thing
to do is to approve the uh proposal as
is but as these have been raised perhaps
a more detailed um investigation could
be undertaken by officers ready for the
next review next year to make sure they
are in line thank you chair thank you
counc pH Mr Holmes thank you chairman
yes there will be a meeting of the um
car park working group would actually be
looking at our car park in charges
across the piece so a number of these
items have been discussed that could
include the hive key can be included in
that when we look at that strategy so
you're absolutely right there will be a
formal review early next year thank you
Mr Holmes uh Mr Spence councelor spenley
Nick spenley please thank you chair um
well with regards to the green waste
there's a number of budget lines under
the broad heading of Waste and Recycling
and in any business or public body you'd
expect an element of cross subsidy so
some lines will be losing and some lines
will be
making what some people might call a
profit but actually isn't uh and will'll
cross subsidize that and as a user of
green uh the Green Waste Service I'd be
happy to to to pay the fee uh I don't
regard it as a tax I regard it as a
service and
um as a generality at the end of uh the
coming year if we find that people have
voted with their feet and the net income
has decreased then we'll know a mistake
was made but I I suggest that we go
ahead with the proposal as laid out on
the paper very much indeed coun been
chairman I I I failed to point out
actually which I should have done that
the strategy resources committee does
not come up with these figures in
isolation the car park working group put
forward its recommendations for all of
the various car parking charges and the
the waste group likewise with the cost
of waste so these have the these haven't
been dreamt out of out of thin air yeah
thank
you what's your point to Clarity Council
fluka um the waste working group
chairman it was where this issue of the
the green beIN and where this figure of
Surplus came from I I I sit on that uh I
sit on that committee chairman and and
my recollection of what went on at that
waste contract working group committee
is certainly different to what the
chairman of strategy and resources just
said I did notice you look at the clock
so I'll sit
down leader
please uh I've know I've not been a
counselor for long yeah as as long as
some of of my fellow members however I
have been a counselor for 4 and a half
years and you I can agree with what the
officer said is is this is this my there
four and a half years these charges have
been the same or has been yeah a
constant or an increase but they haven't
changed at all in the last 4 and a half
years and in terms of any surplus the
thing that we are we are trying to do is
ensure that the green waste collection
pays its way you know we are in terms of
the cost and Council fluke was at the
the waist in terms of the cost to the
council it's below what other councils
are are charging and that's why there's
this increase and one of the things
about our green waste is we actually
collect green waste throughout the
winter compared to our local other local
authorities cult and brain Tre it stops
for three months so in terms of the
service that we're providing it's
actually above what other organ other
councils are do so therefore it is value
for money thank you
Council Jen please thank you chair um I
just wondered where clothing recycling
came into things doesn't seem to be
mentioned at
all we do have a we do have there is
clothing recycling because I it's a blue
sack that's given out and we we we pick
pick that through so thank you I think
clothing's been going for a while soft
Plastics is a trial in certain areas um
okay Mr hes you like to comment yes it
was a it's a curbside collection service
that runs in districts hasn't got a fee
in charge for it so um residents no
residents already put that out and it's
contracted picked up by a
contractor Okay
C we're talking about
Green sorry microphone we talked a about
green waste where only affects those
people who wish to take part of the
scheme far more important is the levels
of childhood obesity across our
district half the kids when they get to
year six are obese and the fact that
we're in increasing the charges for
children's play and sports is scandalous
absolutely scandalous thank you very
much indeed um members i' we've had a
quite a robust debate on it and I'd also
like to thank um councelor fluka for
going through it because it shows and
gives a resident assurance that we all
look through these details with um great
care so I'm going to put the
recommendation now members that we
recommended that the detailed fields and
charges schedule for 2425 has set out an
appendix one to this agenda be agreed
subject to the council's approval of the
fees and charges policy on the 29th of
November
2023 uh I do so move do I have a second
up second thank you very much indeed
that's councilor Pratt has seconded it
can we take that by sent
members vote recorded I don't support it
chair so it's it's counselor your hand
oh sorry your hand was like that so a
bit scary thank you Stevens so any other
people who do not asent to this Okay so
we've got so councelor
stamp so we got councelor
fluka and
me and councelor stilts okay everybody
and you well we're doing it by sent so
no that's that's carried anyway thank
you very much indeed and thank you for
that members um we move on to agenda
item 8 which is minutes of meeting of
the council and this is to note that
since the last Council up until
Wednesday the 6th of December
2023 Council agenda dispatch the
following committees have met and reive
any questions in accordance with Council
committee procedure rule six section two
Central area planning committee on the
22nd of November 2023 strategy and
resources committee on the 23rd of
November 2023 and Licensing committee
the 28th of November 2023 I propose
these are noted do you agree these by
sen agreed thank you very much
indeed move on to agenda item 9
this is a notice of motion and to
consider the following motion that has
been received this is a motion from
Council JC stilts which is motion
17223 and in accordance with notice duly
given under procedure rule four
councelor JC stilts to move the
following motion duly seconded by
councilors as Fluker LJ Haywood mg Neil
and W stamp councelor SS please uh thank
you Mr chair um the motion is is that
the m and hybridge Central area master
plan and action plan of
2017 set out the council's vision and
Ambitions for economic growth through a
regenerative St strategy environmental
enhancements and a Redevelopment of
sites within the master plan
area it was to deliver 18 key projects
over the next 10 to 15 years the molden
and hybridge Central area master plan
incorporates the attractive town of
molden uh molden Town Center the
causeway regeneration area and the
Leisure quarter and forms the district's
Focus for employment retail community
and tourism
facilities prior to the adoption the
plan was not well received by the local
parish and town councils and it is now
considered that the plan is out of date
and no longer meets the needs um meets
the requirements of the district and
that as a consequence Council now
resolves to agree an immediate review to
the 2017 molden and hyridge Central area
master plan and action plan thank you
very much indeed Council STS um before
we move into the debate um I'd like to
call on uh Mr Winslow please to add some
comment and some context thank
you thank you chairman by way of some
background for members uh the molden and
hybridge Central area master plan was
adopted by the council in 2017 as a
supplementary planning document or an
SPD it's a requirement of policy S5 of
the district's local development plan
for the council to have a specific
master plan for the central area which
the ldp defines the area of its role is
to provide further guidance for the
local planning Authority when
determining planning applications in the
central area to deliver the vision set
out in the local development plan and
policy
S5 policy S5 and the master plan SPD
were both developed having been informed
by a series of evidence-based studies
that look to Urban analysis and
Improvement needs a focus study in the
environmental and economic issues at the
causeway and wider regeneration
opportunities given specific assets and
land within the area similar to master
plans elsewhere that consider how to
manage development and change in a
specified area it covers a period of
over 10 years and sets out
uh an action plan um as you've heard of
18 spatially specific projects that are
identified to be worked on during that
time on delivering the master plan the
delivery of the projects however are
dependent on a combination of favorable
planning permission or consents where
they're required funding and work by
other organizations including the
highway Authority developers and land
owners policy S5 of the ldp sets the
policy framework for the master plan
which includes defining the extent of
the central area which includes the
causeway molden High Street he key and
prominade park uh the promotion of the
Town Center is a market town uh which is
proposals for retail office housing
community Leisure being supported by the
development plan in order to contribute
to its regeneration and
diversification the renewal of the
causeway regeneration area to improve
the supply of commercial and industrial
floor space the retention of the central
area for its role in tourism arts and
culture um increasing public access to
the Riverside enhancing public transport
and using effective car park management
to manage traffic and visitor demand and
to protect the sensitive environmental
relationship between the central area
and designated assets including the
river Blackwater and the chela and
Blackwater
navigation as these matters are set out
by the ldp policy S5 should Council be
minded in commissioning a review of the
master plan these would not change as
they cannot be amended outside the ldp
review and will continue therefore to
provide the policy framework for any
revised master plan as part of the ldp
review it was reported to Council on the
3rd of November 2022 as part of the
reconsideration of the ldp policies that
policy S5 itself remains in general
Conformity with national policy and was
therefore not considered to be out of
date in planning
terms turning to the reviewing of the
master plan SPD now as the motion
proposes the council needs to be aware
that the government has prepared reforms
to the planning system through the
leveling up and regeneration act which
has recently received Royal Ascent these
legislative changes will affect
supplementary planning documents like
the master plan uh they will become
supplementary plans in the future and
they will require examination by the
planning inspectorate to determine their
soundness and lawfulness and will have
the same weight as ldp policies in
decision making which is greater than
the weight sbds currently have there
remains some uncertainty at this time as
to how this part of the new system will
work in practice as new National policy
and guidance is still awaited from
government but all Council spds this
council's spds may have to be reviewed
at some point in the future anyway to
ensure they conform with the new system
taking this on board chairman uh if the
council nevertheless minded to review
the m and hridge sentu area master plan
immediately uh the council's decision on
the motion alone tonight cannot make
that happen a report will have to come
back to council proposing an amendment
to the statutary local development
scheme which sets out the planning
policy and guidance preparation program
over the next three years this was last
updated by the council at its meeting in
September where it agreed to Resource
the local development plan review and
prepare a community infrastructure
ructure Levy two spds but not a revision
to the master plan such a report would
need to consider how Council proposes to
fund the master plans update as this was
not part of budget setting
considerations for the next financial
year it would also need to determine the
level of priority to give the Master
Plan update given Staffing Resources are
already allocated in 2024 to the
districtwide ldp review and the planning
obligations SPD while some more work
more work would need to be done to work
out the detail
for it to happen concurrently either
additional Staffing Resources would have
to be considered to be funded or the
work would need to be contracted out if
the council does not want it to impact
on the ldp review program that has
already been agreed thank you thank you
Mr Winslow or members since we've had
the um motion put and the motion
seconded by its very nature um I open
the chamber for debate thank you c a
f uh thank you chairman I mean obviously
it's quite a complex thing to
immediately review this policy um but I
do think it's important that we keep a
track as a council on developments are
coming forward um and have an
understanding of how the current master
plan would develop in the future so I
would propose under the circumstances
that we have a change of wording to the
motion if I have a second that to
suggest that
the policy is brought forward to the
policy planning working group for review
at the earliest opportunity now I
understand that is possibly an
open-ended position but I do think we
have to um encourage officers to bring
it forward as early as possible but
within the time frines of constraints
that they've got within budget and with
the scheme that's put forward um so that
would be my proposal if I have a second
up second second counselor spenley Paula
spenley okay so just to be clear on that
t did you did you get that the proposed
amendment got Theos changing the word in
the motion of the planning policy
working group review the ear opportunity
well I think that one of the easiest
ways to do that with councel still says
it's your motion would you be happy with
that yes um Mr chairman I would be happy
with that it would be nice if we could
have a date so it's not sort of in use
time um so but I would be happy with
that change okay and the second is the
motion are you happy to accept that as
well yep I can see everybody all a
seconders have nodded their head Tara so
we we can take that forward when I put
it to the the table after people have
spoken Council Mick pensy please thank
you chair I agree also I won't so I
won't prolong this uh too long but um I
think certainly um whether it's the
current plan or a future plan it
certainly needs turbocharging um it was
great to see the Christmas Fair
progressed lower down the High Street
than I've seen in previous years but I'm
looking at paragraph 2.81 of the plan
which says the lower end of the High
Street has potential for improvement
which I think is putting it mildly um so
so I think there's a there's a lot of
scope for uh taking this lovely uh area
in which we live with its Rich Heritage
and tourist attractions and creating
these linkages and a new kind of dynamic
so yes I would certainly like to see um
more happening to to see that occur
thank you councelor stamp
please now mine was really to support
councelor fit's Amendment because he
said it was a proposal and it was
important which you did it's an
amendment to our proposal okay thank you
Council Sue White please uh thank you I
just like said I support the um
Amendment um that's been proposed um
because I think these plans do become
outdate fairly quickly and we did a lot
of work in it on it prior to the um
adoption before but obviously the
flooding issues are getting worse and
flooding is one of the things that I
really have a concern with and it's
something I fight very hard for um and I
think that with the updated flooding and
the updating issues it's the right time
to come in and review it and I think
we'll see what the PPG says and we can
perhaps tie it in with the new ldp as
well and so we can get the proposals
coming forward from several several
different directions thank you thank you
coun white and leader
please uh yes thank you yeah I I support
uh councilor fic's amendment to council
Still's motion uh yeah it does need to
come forward as the ldp gets revised and
these plans should be revised as well in
terms of the lower uh part of the High
Street uh that is also part of UK SP SPF
funding uh which will be in phase three
uh so hopefully in terms of some of that
work that will come forward in a couple
of years time thank you any other member
with speak councelor L thank
you thank you Mr chairman yes thank you
for councelor spencec ley's comments
regarding the Christmas Fair the
engagement with the lower part of the
High Street has been very important and
that's happened for a couple of years
now as we've extended it down and
incorporate it you can see the new
businesses now developing at the bottom
of the High Street such as the
introduction of house and the delicatess
and hors skins at the bottom so it's
starting to see that regeneration as the
High Street Coats with some of the
losses like the banks and other
infrastructure at the top so it's a
changing environment that we're trying
to manage obviously with reference to
the plan the feedback and engagement
with the community is essentially really
important as some members attended the
meeting regarding the high key that was
so out of Step where we were and what we
were looking to deliver there was the
the public and the area and the
businesses that around that area really
want to engage with us on this so I
think it's good to bring them with us
when we're doing these things so I
support Council of fit's development and
thank you for the comments again
councilor spencley regarding the fair
yeah thank you very much de councel I
just to be really clear that the the
town it's molden Town Council event so
it's put on so it's just to clarify that
and it's it's not an easy thing to do
and there's a lot of hard work so
appreciation from this Council um before
we move to to the the vote on the motion
I just want to make a comment um the
bottom end of the High Street it always
comes up about the fact that it's over
the bottom end of the High Street but go
and have a look as Council leers said
it's it's started to really have some um
diverse Dynamics about it it's different
there's little shops the micro breweries
reopened again and traditionally by the
nature of the Town The Divide because
it's near the riverfront was always what
we would class as a poorer slightly
rougher area as as any Port Towns
actually have that so it's not as bad as
it's painted to be fair um I don't know
whether I'd want to see 2,000 plants
doesn't sit outside there in the middle
of winter freezing me the bones off um
but yeah it's actually started to
naturally regenerate it and those people
who have moved into there should be
commended for that as as everybody does
in every High Street it's it's tough so
I appreciate everybody's words um so
with the with the amendment there can I
take that um by sent members agreed
agreed okay thank you T are you clear on
everything
there yes thank you very much thank you
very much indeed that's wonderful um we
move on to agenda item 10 which is
questions in accordance with procedure
rule 6 little three of which notice has
been given I have
none uh members we move on to agenda
item number 11 which is the amendment to
the scheme of Delegation which is Page
paid paid found on pages 33 to 36 and
this is to consider the report of the
assistant director of planning and
implantation and Mr quelch the lead
legal specialist and the copy of the
report is enclosed Mr
Winslow uh thank you chairman
um the purpose of the report before
Council concerns the scheme of
Delegation in relation to the post
granting of applications and undertaking
of actions arising from nationally
significant infrastructure projects or
nsips consented by Secretary of State
under powers in the planning Act of 2008
as explained in section 3.1 on page 33
of your reports nsips are granted
consent under a different type of
planning permission called a development
consent order or dco whilst this
decision is not taken by local planning
authorities it's taken by the Secretary
of State the processing of activities
activities sorry similar to discharging
conditions and any enforcement matters
are carried out by the host local
planning authorities as such they are
not dealt within the same way as all
other planning applications determined
by Mor District Council for which our
scheme of Delegation already exists
Council may recall that it's been
engaged um in National highways a12
chelsford to a120 widening scheme
projects since 2017 and in 2022 National
Highway submitted the draft development
consent order to the Secretary of State
for his consideration and determination
via an examination in public Council
approved an engagement mandate in
September 2022 that enabled officers and
W and legal witnesses to represent the
council at the examination and also
established an a12 dco member
consultation group to ensure officers
could remain engaged with relevant
counselors at the examination period
happened sections 3.23 and 3.24 on page
34 of your reports sets out some of the
finer details of how this delegated
Arrangement secured additional measures
into the supporting control documents
for the draft development consent order
which will benefit the MN District
specifically how a gas pipeline will be
diverted through Wick and Bishops and L
little brexit if the a12 dco is approved
molden District Council will become
involved in the Tim restricted process
to ensure the conditions are being met
as agreed and enforce its controls
however as the council has not had an
nsip approved in its District before The
council's Constitution does not already
delegate The Authority for officers to
discharge the responsibilities like it
does for planning applications hence the
amendment to the schem of Delegation is
now sought thank you very much indeed Mr
wiso um members uh before I move to the
uh recommendation leader would you like
to speak yeah thank you chairman um I'd
just like to thank the officers involved
in the a12 project uh for securing
greater protection for the blue Mills
nature reserve and little
braad this was a very new process for
all of the team and they work very hard
in terms of ensuring that we
communicated and we put things forward
in terms of those plans and in terms of
ensuring that we protect protect those
areas so I I I I'm going to read out
those who I'd really like to thank in
terms of their work um and that's uh Mr
Winslow sitting to my left uh Derek
Lawrence Annie Keane fion Bradley and
Jackie Longman in terms of their work in
terms of doing this new thing for the
council and doing such a good job thank
you leader so I put the recommendation
to the the chamber that the scheme of
Delegation is amended to give the
director of Service delivery in
conjunction sorry in consult I got my
teeth in tonight in consultation with
the chairperson of the district planning
committee the following de delegated
power following the grant of a
development consent order by the
Secretary of State and or anybody
appointed by him the ability to make any
post-grant decisions required of the
council including planning enforcement
in relation to the development this is
the recommendation do I have a second
there please a second that Council
councelor Pratt second that thank you
members over to you councelor
darham yeah thank you yeah I Echo what
the leader said in in in that yes we did
have some success with blue Mills
Conservation Area I'm afraid that was
about it um there was considerable
amount of I'll call it consultation in
its crudest form um carried out in
respect of the various options and
directions for the a12 and its widening
scheme we were consulted as were assets
County Council as were most of the other
authorities along that line
and I'm afraid um National highways or
highways England whatever they're called
this week basically ignored absolutely
every single consultation response and
did exactly what they wanted and they're
putting the road exactly where they
wanted so yes I understand with these
nend siips we we need this Ste scheme of
Delegation I rather hope that our next
endp is Brad well be but um obviously I
support this recommendation thank you um
I just quote I absolutely hope that our
n is absolutely never Bradwell be the
distra ruction of that beautiful pinula
doesn't sit well and the production of a
thousand years of waste doesn't sit well
with me either and it's a difference of
opinion thank you councelor stamp yeah
thank you forgive you for me not
standing up I'm a bit tired at the
minute I'm lot of meetings like
everybody else I support what councelor
durhams actually said I mean I sat
through some of these consultations that
went on for absolute hours and nobody
gave an absolute damn about what people
said in this District um it could have
been better designed it could have taken
more things into account
and for once councelor Durham I do agree
with you thank you
chair okay concern there thank you any
other member wish to speak on this this
agenda item councelor white thank you uh
thank you Mr chairman I mean yeah I mean
mine is the same all thing with
consultations they send the
consultations out they ask you give
their responses and they completely
ignore all the responses that come back
um you know we are where we are we don't
really have very much to say in these
the only thing I would say is although
I'm okay with the delegation I do think
that as members we need to be kept
updated via emails and
bulletins um so that we can have two-way
traffic so we can raise issues as they
arise as well because it will affect
everybody and we must have input thank
you thank you counc Mr Winslow would you
like to respond to the being kept
updated the methodology for that um
sorry uh yes chairman I think we can uh
certainly accomodate a member update um
as the a12 project construction um uh
continues uh in a similar way as we have
with the a12 examination thank you very
much indeed anybody else before I put it
to the chamber note Okay memb so we've
had a oh sorry c s leader yeah I just
want to say that the uh consultation for
the wards that are affected by the
upgrade of the a12 so uh wiin Bishops
and and the totam ward have been heavily
involved uh in terms of working with
officers and the process so those
directly by affected by uh the a12
upgrade we have had an awful lot of
consultation and that has been extremely
valuable thank you yeah they did well
the the officers did but the a12 the
highways
didn't yeah that's wonderful so members
we have the recommendation um it has
been seconded by councelor PR do we
agree that by our same members agreed
that's unanimous thank you very much
indeed members we move on to agenda item
12 which is the schedule of meetings
2024 to 2025 which is p found on pages
37 to 40 um it's a report by Miss H but
I believe um the director of strategy
resources is going to deliver this Mr
dos yes thank you thank you chairman um
yes as the report highlights since
February 2019 the the council has been
working to an agreed six week weekly
cycle of of meetings around Council um
and this large ually takes that forward
into the next year and appendix one um
presents a schedule for the year um for
members to to comment or approve thank
you chairman thank you very much indeed
Mr doson members it's the reports are
pretty clear to do we agree this by
Ascent agre thank you members U again we
move on with Mr Dodson who's going to
give us a verbal update on the sxy
Devolution process thank you Mr
dson thank you chairman um this will be
a short update because I think it it was
two weeks ago that I I previously
updated council at the the extraordinary
meeting and and largely nothing has
changed during that period um the I
believe at that point there had just
been a a letter sent um by
the uh minister to the MPS within um
Essex
um answering the queries that they had
raised in a meeting and subsequently
there have been meetings and and
discussions around that and I believe
there have been some responses but as
yet there's no indication whether the uh
secretary of state will look to um make
a decision and I'm not expecting that
now to be before Christmas and members
will remember that the last time I spoke
I suggested that if there wasn't a
decision by Christmas then may be
challenging to deliver a Devolution deal
in full through the consultation process
and and everything else that needs to be
um agreed um within the life of this
Parliament so not a very positive update
but but nothing more that I can can
really advise on thank you chair thank
you very much indeed Mr Dodson uh we
move on to agenda item 14 which is
questions to the leader of the council
in accordance with procedure rule one
section 3M uh we we have um any members
wish to raise a question councelor stamp
any other member so I can just capture
so I don't miss councelor Fluker any
other member please so councelor stamp
first please yeah thank you um Can the
um leader give us an update on any
meetings that he's had not just with ESS
County Council regarding the leveling up
but with any other um outside body at
the minute that is relevant to that all
members should know rather than
obviously just leaders and deputies is
and could I actually ask that if uh in
future something could be put on the
agenda so all members are actually up to
date with with any meetings that you're
attending thank you thank you yeah
obviously I'm more than happy to update
members about any meetings that I'm
attending uh so just to give you an
update in terms of leveling up one of
the concerns that uh the that myself and
I think other members had was around
everyone's esss and the fact that in
terms of the government in terms of D du
luck I can never say that correctly I
want to say
duux uh in terms of them they do uh say
as an authority that we are a level one
Authority however there's a huge
discrepancy between that and how what
Essex thinks and essic does not include
us as a level one Authority Under
everyone's essics
so myself and Miss Button had a meeting
with the deputy uh leader of uh Essex
along with two of their
officers to discuss that and to try and
Lobby for molden to be included under
everyone esses and to me this is
particularly important if Devolution
does go ahead because it would be essics
that would then be allocating funds
to level one
authorities so we had a good
conversation with the representatives
from
ethics however they weren't prepared to
move because they under their
consideration the only reason that the
government says that we're a level one
Authority is because of the lack of
Transport infrastructure and the rural
nature we argued that point because one
of the things about brain tree District
Council who is included which is
included in everyone eics is it's not
the whole of the brain tree District
Council it's what they consider the
rural part of brain tree District
Council over transport issues so there's
a real discrepancy there so we try to
put that position however there was
still a negative response from Essex
County Council now I'm not the sort of
person who will give up and I think that
the council needs to Lobby further in
terms of this and try and get more
movement yeah I think we've got to wait
and see what happens with Devolution as
well at the same time um we are going to
write to our MPS about it as as well and
and and and see whether they're
interested in being and we mentioned it
to the MPS at the MP's meeting so uh
hopefully it's not going to be end we
need to we need to continue this process
so when we do the next phase hopefully
what I'll do and I think would be a
really good idea is to get all members
support on this and have a group letter
you and a group Lobby in terms of all
the members of of the council in terms
of move trying to move this forward so
very frustrating um and thank you for
raising the question uh because I think
it's really important to this Council in
terms of other meetings I've had more
informal ones recently you obviously I
went to the greater ethics uh leaders
meeting the thing about some of those
is uh is is what's it doing what's it
achieving what's it what are the results
too much of a talking shop uh one
interesting thing is in terms of the
non-conservative leaders because there
are a lot more of them in essence we are
meeting having our own meetings and
discussing things and discussing how we
move things forward uh as I may remember
last time uh I said I'd attended the neb
meeting and and as a result of that you
I became chair of of neeb in January
I'll be having meetings with the
officers of neeb to start looking at how
we move the action plan forward and one
of the things I I had an initial meeting
with the with the officers from neep um
and one of the things I said to them at
that particular meeting was I am
concerned that it
too Urban focused and not District
focused so that's something that I will
be lobbying and ensuring that in terms
of the action plan we really take into
account the rural districts and the
rural needs in terms of any Economic
Development because I think that's
really really important thank you very
much indeed councelor
fluka yeah thank you the time permitting
chairman I've I've I've got three
questions um the first one chairman I I
did try to put this to council earlier
but I'm sure the leader will can I ask
you just to speak up a little bit even
I'm struggling to hear you sorry and I'm
a young Spirit young person um chairman
um I did try to bring this up early but
leader I'm sure you'll agree with me um
and pay tribute to Mr galum and Mr
swords um both of whom went the extra
mile last Friday afternoon um to help
one of my vulnerable constituents with a
safeguarding issue I mean I think it's
you know really really important for for
members you know we particularly the
role I play in South Min I'm
continuously being contacted by
residents and in this particular
occasion chairman there was a very
vulnerable person who was in a very
difficult position and I I I'm I'm I'm
grateful to Mr gay and Mr SS for helping
me out particularly on the Friday
afternoon and uh and I'm I'm sure Mr
Holmes will extend my thanks to both of
them um moving on chairman um leader
since you've become leader the only two
policies you brought forward in your own
name uh are stopping the area plan
stopping the area planning committees in
favor of one committee and reducing the
number of motions allowed at Council
meetings you V Rec recently voted
against the council's preliminary
schedule of cost savings and it now
looks like the savings policies that are
emerging are all officer Le initiatives
and that said and bearing in mind
excluding investment income uh annual
deficits will soon be in excess of £2.5
million can you tell the
residents what in your capacity of
leader of more District independent
group what your policy is on making
savings or am I correct that you don't
have any and you're just being fed by
officers thank you I've got another
question well it's very interesting it's
very actually useful that the lead that
the Adrian Council Fluker even if I
could all it's one of those days it's
December and it's the end of the year uh
I'm very pleased that councilor fluga
has uh put forward that question
because on last Friday with the other
leaders from the groups including the
district support group we went through
the corporate plan and identified and I
worked with those leaders to identify
what in terms of the current corporate
plan what our priorities are and on
Monday I went through with that with
with the corporate leadership team to
focus on what we need to do in
2425 in terms of our priorities and in
terms of where we need to focus on what
we're doing and ensuring that we remain
cost effective and the B budgets are
balance I I dispute that it's two and a
half million because I don't really
think that's an upto-date figure
councelor fluka one of the things that
we will be doing and one of the things I
really want to happen within the next
six months or so so based on the
resident survey based on the finance
survey is to use that information to
update our corporate pan and again I've
discussed this with the corporate
leadership team and what I'd really like
to happen because unfortunately last in
the last Municipal year the corporate
plan was rushed for some reason so and
there was very little member involvement
in terms of that corporate plan so what
I'd really like to happen and one of the
things again we discussed is as we move
to the next Municipal year is that all
members have an opportunity to influence
that corporate plan have their ideas
also look at our corporate projects also
look at what we need to do in across the
district in terms of new projects and
spend yeah how how we might spend any
level one money that comes to this
Authority ensure that everybody is
involved in that Ure everybody has a say
in how we might influence and how we
might shape the district as you all know
I have no strategy Powers anybody who's
been a leader at this Council knows
because we're not our cabinet system I
have no statutary Powers one of the
things that we are doing and one of the
things that we're doing in terms of the
molden district independent group is we
had a really strong Manifesto at that
last election and that Manifesto is
what's influencing what we might do in
terms of that corporate plan and but
what I'm trying to do because we don't
have a overall control is bring the
other leaders on this journey and it to
be a joint process because I think
that's really really important and
that's what we' been doing since August
is have a joint process with all the
other political groups and ensuring that
everybody's had a say and I think that's
been really constructive and if we can
continue that it can only make can only
be of benefit to the council and to our
residents thank you we still have time
councelor Fluker if you wish to raise a
second
question that in depth answer as well um
leader the uh the deputy leader of the
council is absent again he's already
missed more than a quarter of all formal
meetings this information is on the
council website where you will all see
your attendance levels uh that he's been
expected at and his attendance levels at
working groups and other meetings has
been described as woeful given he given
he has paid an additional £
5,425 to be Deputy leader do you agree
with me that that hardly represents good
value to local
taxpayers one of things that we all know
is that we have different priorities in
our life and at times in our personal
lives there are other things that take
over we have to have a balance between
those things we have to ensure that
people's personal needs are also
reflected in terms of what they have to
do and that's what I feel is
important the deputy leader attends
every sing single meeting with me
outside of this room the deputy leader
comes to all those things and has been
invaluable in terms of his
support we can't always make meetings
and we have to understand that but the
deputy leader has my full
support thank you very much indeed thank
you any other questions to the leader
because we have 90
seconds quick one um at a scrutiny
meeting today I found it really
interesting we was reviewing uh how and
why and Lessons Learned for councils
that have gone
bankrupt and uh it was actually really
good very very positive meeting very
interesting lots of detail and one of
the things and this is to the leader one
of the things that was a Common Thread
through many of them that went bankrupt
was um building new offices moving and
re um going from their old offices
rather than I'm going to add this this
wasn't mentioned but the retrofitting so
can I actually suggest to the leader you
actually think about that because I know
there is a push to most probably get rid
of this and there's been discussions
about it but I can caution you that a
majority of the councils and admittedly
some of them are bigger they've all gone
bankrupt so when you do look at that can
I make can you make sure you do
scrutinize and do proper risk
assessments when assessing it to make
sure that we are not going to go from
the firing pan Into the Fire it's true I
can prove it thank C very shortly leader
please thank you I I agree
wholeheartedly yeah and the at the end
of the day this is our residents money
so we have to ensure that whatever we do
is right for the council and right for
the the residents if we stay here we
need to look at how we use it and the
way that we use it because at the moment
it's not environmentally friendly it's
not green enough it's not yeah there's
all lots of issues with this building so
we we've got to make the right decision
both for the council and for the
district what that decision is I now at
this stage thank you thank you members
for your question thank you leader for
we've out of time so we're out of time
Cil sorry yeah um number 15 which is an
agenda item business by reasons of
special circumstances considered by the
chairman to be urgent I have none we
move on to agenda item 16 which is the
exclusion of the public and the press
and this is to resolve that under
Section 104 of the Local Government Act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that it involves
a likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph 3 of
part one of schedule 12a to the ACT and
that this satisfies the public interest
test members I so move read thank you
members Tara if you
could